el lugar por donde han desfilado
despampanantes carrozas hoy sólo
transitan los vehículos de quienes
buscan protegerse del cob y 19 el
sambódromo de río de janeiro debía estar
preparándose para la celebración del
carnaval pero hoy está convertido en un
centro de vacunación y agua si abro
samboal estamos abriendo el sambódromo
para vacunar a las personas de forma
organizada sin agitación gente que
podría tener problemas para moverse por
tener más de 90 años por lo que están
siendo vacunadas dentro de su automóvil
nada de a todo propio como el carnaval
de río se había aplazado para mitades de
año pero por primera vez en un siglo uno
de los eventos más famosos del mundo no
se llevará a cabo el objetivo es seguir
evitando aglomeraciones mientras brasil
lucha contra un virus que ha cobrado la
vida de más de 230.000 personas la
segunda peor cifra a nivel global cada
año este es un lugar de júbilo para
miles de brasileños y visitantes
extranjeros pero hoy también lo es para
aquellos que confían en la campaña de
vacunación que me recibieron muy bien
estoy muy feliz muy satisfecha hasta me
dan ganas de llorar
he esperado tanto este momento es una
buena sensación saber que ella estará
protegida no ahora sino con la segunda
dosis
brasil inició su jornada de inmunización
a mitades de enero y además de comprar
el país también ya está produciendo
dosis de las inyecciones de la empresa
china sinovac y de la británica
astrazéneca con el fin de vacunar a sus
210 millones de habitantes